DENT TRUMP IN  AIAVESTIGSTON
PRTIAL ES MENTIONED THE
SIDE WITTH  COUNTY ELECTION B T.
THEY SPEWED THE  PURPOSE O THE T
AS
AND HE TO DISCUSTRATEGIST ANCNL
DECIONONA  MIGHT RECALL, YOU REE
FOR BIDEN ON EIOMOSTTHG
CN D
TH UATERE FIRED BY
DE
DESICALL ARINAYOU DI
FOR ARIZA R BIDEN.
O OU
KNOW WHABE
FRIDENT.
WHATS HAPPENING INZO
THOUGHTS  NG IS, BIL
SALMY GREAT  MLLERDS WHO WE RE T
SK IN THE SISS YEARS.
WT ONE, TOO.
>> NO QUESTION ANDAN
E E CALL I IT LO
DI UIM
WAS ACCURATEAND WHATUL
D THERE  IIENCE WIAS
BEHEORY CHPTED ANARRATIVE THAT N
BRA
E WON.WHEN HE SAID WE  T  ONETHS
PE CONSIGAN,
ARIZONA, THAT EVER WWA
TH WERE WATCHIOUS
WATC.D ONA, REDLUT THAT HE --UMH
T?T HAVE ALL --
HIS WASN'T JUST ONE OF THOSE
>> NO,S A IP
THAT H
NEED PENNSNIOO FROM SYLVANIA.
ANGRY ABERSTAN
ANE CALL BECAUSE IT
DISRUPTEA  HE
INLAOULECTION. UREPHE
OTWERE BPHONE LINE F EXECUTIVES
O CHANGEHIS CALL YOU
AD YOU PICK UP ON ANY O
THOSDIONS?
>> YAN PAY ATTENO AY ON , THEYMR
SNYEOPLE.
AND I CA
McCATHINK  STEVE SCA.
I CAN THOFED REPUBLICANS THAT W.
AND THAT GENUINEURAT HAPPENED D
WEEKS AFTER THATS TRULY
SHOWONF MANITYHEY DID AND HOW T
THEY KNEW BETTER, WAS GENUINELY
SURPRISING TO ME.
IF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY T
THEY HE TO D OS WILL BE A -- AO
>> AND IAK
EVEN MORE MADDINTHAT Y
TO CALL TINDSU , THISST  DELUSA
UPENE ARIZRE
IT PROBABLY WON'T EVER
LET ME JUST SA
NUR SETAR
FACTY
DN'TE SULT OECTIONTOE BANKK
S OF THOSEION,
SI O YOUNOW,HE
NG
BURUE.CAT S A STATE
AT CAMPAIG
BUT YOU HAO E GG P WE'RE LOOKITI
N INTE TRP,
GIULIANI,  TNGES TO THE
ELECTIONTIS,D AR A SOMAN
WE ARE SEEAU
NG BUT THAT ISGOING TO ENDD IT'T
G TO BE A NEW RE TRS THAT WE SA
ELECTION NIGNDLOW.
ME OFALLED AUDIT THAT IHAPPENI.
THIS QUEST FOR BAMBOO BALLOTS
ELON EVERY-FOUR YEARS, HOWTTY I?
WEL -- FIRST THING, S I LOVE YY
>> BUTHEA DANG
REPUANKING UP TO THE
BATOHETHINGSHAT.ENTLY, THEY
PIECEAT
TU A PTI
UR
S.E WO
LEGISLATION, DOINGSE AS,THER S.
BASE AND FOLKS IN THEIR O THINTH
WITH THE.
NTHENSIVE WORK ON
PU THE ELECTION?
THTH
OVER HILLARY CLIIG
PARTY WITH EMBRACING
VA.HA TALK TO
THESE VERYER ATHIS ST  THE WAY
SHENANIG TOLISHN
TWTS.
TH
MEMIE --'T GET OVERS
WHAT -- WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT?
I THINWEAKCSUT
AND REALIZE THIS IHE
RE SHOUL-- FROM VE HET
HAVE BEEN ULD THLD US TO DO.
ANI Y TH WE CT ANDOU EERISAT, NO
VACC DYOU IN .'TR  LOT O
LIKEWEARASI  I
THERE IS THEUEABOUT A
LOT OF THESE STATES THAT
MASKEAACCINES.OM
NOTION THAT'S  WITH MAYOK SCOTT
AND HE SAYS WE NEED JUST TREPUB
ARCOUNTRNT
F THEY
E NEED EDUCATE ICERICANS ARE NCI
ABOUT THE SAFEF GEG A
VACCIN>>LET YOU GO
UM, Y  FOXYO
UM,  HLLINDING ONNDCOVID VACCIN.
AR
>> WOULD PUT IT TH
WAY.
THNG.
THEY'RE OR PEOWI LOW -ECAUSE YOT
YOU KNOW.
SIDE.'T OR THERE.I -- I WASN'T N
IT IS POOR PEOPLE WITH LOWINMEN.
SIRE NOTING PEOPLE.ING THE  JOHN
HEY'RE MAKING